you are one of the best playoff
performers ever in the history of our
league so I wanted to build your
all-time clutch playoff team assuming
you're you're already on the roster so
you already on this roster I'm going
give you 12 bucks and you have to build
your your alltime playoff clutch team
and obviously Tom Brady is at $5 and we
got grank at $5 too so you could I you
could you could use both of those guys I
know you love those guys but then we had
to settle for Hans Ward and marshan ly
but if you could use this $12 how would
you build your alltime playoff cach I
think $5 is already going to Tom Brady
right yeah without a doubt I mean it's a
quarterback League got gotta pay you get
the quarterback right you're gonna be
all right so we're going
TB um now who would T see Jerry Jerry's
too
expensive cuz you got to go I I already
know know you you got to go
grank I'll give grank and how is Mara
how is Marshawn a dollar I'm taking
Mara I I didn't set this up I didn't set
this up but and then we got to go with
Hans Ward we gotta go hin Ward and you
already on you already on the roster too
you already on the roster too so it's
good actually then I got I gotta go back
I gotta I'm on this roster so I got to
go back ah you already on you already on
the team this this not including you so
do I got I go Kelsey and then
to I might have to go but you know
Kelsey see grank up that scam he can
like you know like Kelsey might take
some of my
rocks you know and he already got so
many rocks everybody man n put back that
on grock you gotta go with grock and me
and hdes this Tom would I don't know if
Tom would necessarily pick
this this
is I think I think we can win win I
think we can win with this I think Hines
War everybody on there already won a
Super Bowl already man so I think we can
I mean how can
Mar you know sometimes you know
sometimes prices drop man this is this
is a this is like clearly like this
would be a physical a physical way of
winning you know Hines W going and block
the force Marsha you know we give him
the ball hit that play action to grank
right up the
scene man that's that's super dope man I
like I I can ride with this too man I
obviously I could go
with if I
was man if I wouldn't pick Brady I'd
pick
Joe Joe Joe Mont I love Joe I grew up a
Niners fan Big Joe Mont fan oh that's
doe so I go Joe I would go Joe Tio
Marshon grank if I if I couldn't pick
Tom if I couldn't pick Tom you said it's
Joe to mar mar
grank we can we can win with if I could
pick gr two then I would go Travis
too
Maran
Travis too
Marsha Tom but this is my team if if I
could pick those
two